so remember earlier this week when i
said the democrats were stuck on stupid
it seems joe biden didn't learn anything
from his party overwhelming failure in
virginia after republican yunkan flipped
the state red it should have been
obvious to democrats that voters don't
support the left's anti-america agenda
instead of switching gears and trying to
do what's right for the country joe
biden is
reportedly looking to give failed
gubernatorial candidate terry mccullough
a job in the white house
must have something to do with his dance
moves here to react now caitlin
mackinnon co-host of outnumbered an
author uh for such a time as this and
dave rubin host of the reuben report
um dave i'm gonna go straight to you
it seems like they're not really
catching the message but but maybe they
are and they're stuck on corruption um
the voters rejected him he's a former
donor a fundraiser of the democratic
party so why not just put him in the
white house
well first off you're totally right that
the dance moves alone should have
disqualified the guy but this is what
the left consistently does they they
never never look in the mirror and say
hey
maybe people are upset about
indoctrinating kids into all this
critical race theory stuff maybe kid
parents are upset that we're teaching
everyone that america is systemically
racist and the founding of the country
is bad and that boys are girls and two
plus two doesn't equal four and all
these things instead of looking at any
of that say taking out a mirror and
going maybe we're overstepping here just
a little bit uh they always double down
and they they fail up i mean what is it
that terry mcauliffe is skilled in i i
honestly have no idea so the idea he'd
make his way to the administration
really doesn't make much sense
kaylie maybe he can teach them what not
to do
yeah i mean let's hope i you know dave
rubin poises a very good question what
does he have to offer well he is the
king of the establishment this guy is
the ultimate insider lawrence you travel
all across the country much like i do
you talk to people you hear what they're
thinking and there is a clear and
distinct distaste for washington it's
existed since before president trump
ever came in it persists even now
that that's the reason that youngkin a
guy with a two percent name
identification who had never run for
political office
never been a politician before came in
and took down the ultimate insider he
took him down because he did what was
most important talking to the concern of
parents getting on the level of the
everyday americans he didn't make this
about trump he didn't make this about
you know left versus right he made this
about the person he was looking at in
that crowd and he had massive crowds by
the way uh so he beat the establishment
by talking to the people that's what
this is about so bring in the ultimate
insider joe biden not gonna help you
turn around the 38 approval rating that
you currently have you know dave you
cited education and that was a part of
it but then you got the economy you got
him walking out of interviews when
they're talking about public safety i
mean you can go from issue to issue and
he just wasn't prepared this was just a
prime example of what the democratic
party at large believed and the voters
rejected it
yeah absolutely look there aren't really
any moderate democrats left like i
believe there's individual pockets
there's some liberals say bill maher who
occasionally gets some stuff right but
the democratic party has really moved
way left and for anyone that's on the
right if you're a conservative a
libertarian you're just a disaffected
liberal it's like the message needs to
be pretty simple i think it's just hey
we think america is pretty good we don't
want the government to do everything we
don't believe in mandates we want you to
make some choices for yourself we
actually believe in science rather than
just saying we believe in science that's
a winning message right now two years
into the covid thing if you're walking
around going oh i just wish the
government had more of my money and more
power over my life then then you're
really mistaken so i think there's a
huge opportunity right now just for the
republicans to say hey we're sane
they're not you know
it goes something like this leave me
alone leave me alone leave my money
alone leave my kids alone uh
leave my guns alone i mean leave my
border alone just just leave us alone i
think that's what a lot of voters are
saying uh dave kaley thanks so much for
joining the program tonight
thanks lawrence you bet a special
veteran day guest actor gary sinise who
is changing lives of wounded veterans
across america he joins us next